[Musique]
suffit pour jouer moi
une bataille musicale à la mairie ce
samedi 9 novembre sept groupes du bassin
yvelinois compositeur et interprète se
sont produits sur scène pour cette
quatrième édition du tremplin fait des
groupes à la merise ça représente
peut-être un tremplin ou peut-être en
tout cas déjà touché toucher des gens
principalement quand il ya plein de
groupes locaux et c'est ça qui est
intéressant de pouvoir rencontrer aussi
des musiciens du département quoi il ya
des beaux concerts et un beau jury c'est
l'opportunité de jouer dans des
conditions professionnelles
et encore une fois dense à l'ancrage
local c'est à côté de chez nous
et en attendant les sept groupes
présents ont été sélectionnés sur
plusieurs mois chaque groupe candidate
déjà dans les critères il faut que ça
soit des compositions 6 et des reprises
on ne prend pas des groupes ensuite
deuxièmement faut vraiment qu'ils soient
du bassin pourrait que nous on fait une
première écoute
voilà et de là on sélectionne pas entre
sept et huit groupes et ensuite ils
passent devant nous sur scène dans des
conditions réelles et est reparti ce
moment là bas via un vote à la fois du
public mais également du jury le jury
composé de professionnels du son de
directeur de celles aidées lui accorde
20 minutes sur ce n est pas une seconde
de plus le jury vote sur la fois la
présence scénique la musicalité le texte
la technicité et là on finit avec une
note à 20 dont une note de 1 à 5 pour
chacun de ces paramètres et on finit
avec note voilà sur 20 après
délibération cette année le gagnant du
tremplin et finalement thiec du rap
venons de trappes pas besoin de temps
plein je lui pardonne à mai
on a livré un gros plat de diable
hommage et le groupe remporté un passage
sur la scène de la brise en première
partie d'un spectacle pour les entendre
il faudra patienter jusqu'à la prochaine
saison culturelle 2020 2021